Off 1.
Le 8 novembre 2016, les États-Unis d’Amérique
se déchirent comme rarement auparavant.
Suite à l’annonce des résultats et l’élection
de Donald Trump, un contraste saisissant se
dessine.
D’un côté, une extasie pleine de joie
et d’espoir accueille chaleureusement cette
nouvelle inespérée.
De l’autre, des larmes de haine et des cris
de désespoir accompagnent une angoisse poignante.
Rarement les États-Unis ont été si divisés.
Off 2.
Les médias américains sont couverts d’hyperboles.
Les uns voient enfin la lumière au bout du
tunnel.
Les autres annoncent le pire et s’arment
déjà pour une lutte de tous les instants.
Et pendant ce temps, les études sociologiques
le confirment.
Les américains se sont de plus en plus polarisés.
Ils se sont complètement isolés dans l’un
des deux camps politiques.
La marijuana contre la religion.
La gay pride contre la sainteté du mariage.
L’avortement contre la vie.
Les aides à l’internationale contre le
protectionnisme.
Les aides sociales contre la réduction des
impôts.
Les écologistes contre le développement
économique.
L'interdiction des armes contre la liberté
de les posséder.
Les hippies contre les conservateurs.
L'égalité contre la sécurité.
La redistribution des richesses contre la
réduction des charges sur les entreprises.
Le progrès contre les traditions.
Les villes contre les campagnes.
Il y a de bonnes chances que vous tombiez
systématiquement du même côté du débat.
N’est-ce pas étrange ? Pourquoi est-ce
que chacun d’entre nous n’arrive pas à
être plus mixte dans nos opinions sur tous
ces sujets de société ? Comment se fait-il
que votre réponse à l’une de ces questions
me suffise à prédire la plupart de vos réponses
aux autres questions ?
Je sais ce que vous vous dites.
Vous vous dites que les gens dans le camp
opposé sont tous stupides.
Que votre camp est le bon camp.
Que vous avez raison.
Mais quelle est la probabilité que les gens
stupides de l’autre camp soient tous d’accord
sur autant de sujets différents ? Comment
se fait-il que des gens stupides n’aient
pas des opinions plus mixtes et plus aléatoires
? Et puis, êtes-vous sûr que les gens de
votre camp sont vraiment plus intelligents
que ceux du camp opposé ?
Rien n’est moins sûr.
Le niveau d’éducation, notamment une fois
contrôlé vis-à-vis des facteurs de confusion
tels que la pression des pairs subie par les
personnes éduquées, n’est pas si bon prédicateur
de l’idéologie.
Et puis, après tout, l’Histoire des sciences
et de la philosophie a montré que des personnes
très éduquées se retrouvaient sur un spectre
idéologique très étendu.
À l’instar des américains, quelque chose
semble diviser toutes les démocraties du
monde plus que jamais.
Et les chiffres qui révèlent cette fracture
idéologique sont effrayants.
Off 3.
Au cours des dix dernières années, les américains
se sont de plus en plus polarisés, sous le
mandat d’un Barack Obama qui disait pourtant
vouloir les unifier.
Off 3.
Sur des questions typiques du débat Républicain
versus Démocrate, les réponses des américains
sont de plus en plus systématiquement celles
du parti avec lequel ils s’identifient.
Les différences géographiques se sont aussi
accentuées.
Les news feeds se sont radicalisés.
Off 3.
Désormais, la grande majorité des comtés
sont très nettement remportés, que ce soit
par un Démocrate ou un Républicain.
Pire encore, l’opinion d’un camp au sujet
de l’autre s’est profondément agravé.
Off 3.
Aujourd’hui, 45% des Républicains pensent
que l’idéologie Démocrate est une menace
à l’avenir des États-Unis, tandis que
41% des Démocrates pensent que l’idéologie
Républicaine est dangereuse pour l’avenir
des États-Unis.
Et l’accession au pouvoir de Donald Trump
ne semble qu’amplifier cette scission idéologique
nationale, jour après jour.
À tel point, qu’aujourd’hui, c’est
cette scission idéologique grandissante qui
m’inquiète le plus.
Je dirais même qu’il s’agit là de l’une
de mes plus grandes inquiétudes pour le futur
de l’humanité.
Je la trouve plus préoccupante encore que
les pires idéologies des hommes politiques.
Mais mettons mes tourments de côté.
Posons-nous l’une des questions les plus
fascinantes qui soient.
Pourquoi les gens pensent-ils ce qu’ils
pensent ? Et en particulier dans notre cas,
pourquoi se sont-ils polarisés comme ce fut
le cas ? Et surtout, que doit-on faire pour
dépolariser les convictions politiques ?
Il s’agit là de vastes questions.
On peut mentionner en vrac les biais de confirmation,
la pression des pairs, l’heuristique de
disponibilité, le plaisir de l'aisance cognitive
et tout plein d’autres erreurs logiques
dont nos crétins de cerveaux sont constamment
victimes.
Mais en tant que théoricien des jeux, ce
qui m’intéresse, ce sont surtout les causes
systémiques.
En particulier, j’aimerais savoir si modifier
la structuration de nos sociétés pourrait
conduire à des résultats différents.
Et là, il y a bien sûr le phénomène des
et des épidémies idéologiques
dont on reparlera dans un prochain épisode.
Mais pour aujourd’hui, j’aimerais avancer
une explication qui n’est que trop rarement
avancée à mon goût.
J’affirme que c’est notre système démocratique
lui-même qui conduit inéluctablement à
cette bipolarisation idéologique de nos sociétés.
Et pour comprendre pourquoi, revenons en 2002.
Off 4.
C’est un tremblement de terre qui secoue
la France.
On est le 21 avril 2002.
À la suite du premier tour de l’élection
présidentielle, la gauche de Lionel Jospin
s’est fait éliminée par le Front National
de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
Jospin, humilié par cet échec monstrueux,
annonce la fin de sa carrière politique le
soir même.
Au second tour, le taux de votants augmente
de plus de 10%, et Jacques Chirac deviendra
président à une très, très, très large
majorité.
Pourquoi Jospin s’est-il fait éliminé
dès le premier tour ? Et bien, c’est parce
qu’il était donné favori.
Parce que Jospin était favori et que personne
ne doutait de sa présence au second tour,
la gauche s’est divisée.
Cette année là, les candidats à gauche
étaient très nombreux.
Mais surtout, les électeurs de gauche ont
éparpillé leurs votes.
L’extrême-gauche, en particulier, a connu
des résultats inhabituellement élevés.
Et c’est là que réside le paradoxe tragique
de notre système électoral.
En se présentant ou en votant ce qu’ils
voulaient voté, les candidats et électeurs
de gauche se sont auto-poignardés en favorisant
l’issue qui leur déplaît le plus, à savoir
l’absence d’un candidat de gauche au second
tour.
C’est pour ça que l’on a désormais des
primaires dans les deux grands partis politiques
aujourd’hui.
C’est pour éviter l’éparpillement des
voix qu’a subi la gauche en 2002.
Ces primaires sont tellement devenues courantes
de nos jours qu’on ne se pose même plus
la question de leurs légitimités, leur pertinence
ou leur raison d'être dans notre système
démocratique.
Tout comme on ne questionne même plus le
fait qu’il n’y ait que deux grands partis
politiques.
Pourtant, il est bien là le problème de
notre système démocratique.
Parce qu’il n’y a que deux grands partis
politiques, on est poussé à adhérer à
un camp parmi 2.
Et si cela n’est encore qu’à moitié
vrai en France, outre-Atlantique, c’est
on-ne-peut-plus le cas.
Et si c’est encore plus le cas là-bas qu’ici,
ce n’est pas parce que les américains sont
plus idiots.
C’est parce que leur système démocratique
les pousse encore plus à se diviser en deux
camps politiques et à ne jamais s’en éloigner.
Off 5.
Le vrai système de vote américain est d’une
complexité atroce et d’un arbitraire désastreux.
Je ne vais pas rentrer dans ces détails.
Mais en première approximation, on peut voir
qu’il s’agit d’une élection à un tour.
Et vous voyez le problème avec l’élection
à un tour ?
Off 5.
L’éparpillement des voix est un problème
bien plus immédiat ! Ainsi, le jour où la
Démocrate Hillary Clinton devint candidate
à la présidentielle de 2016 fut le jour
où les idées du démocrate Bernie Sanders
furent tuées dans l’oeuf.
Pour commencer, si Sanders se présentait
à son tour, il volerait des voix à Clinton
et garantirait quasiment immédiatement l’élection
de Trump.
Comme Sanders était idéologiquement plus
proche de Clinton que de Trump, il avait donc
tout intérêt à ne pas se présenter.
Plus généralement, une fois qu’il y a
deux candidats importants, tout citoyen a
intérêt à ne pas se présenter, puisqu’il
défavorise alors le candidat dont il est
le plus proche, et favorise celui qu’il
ne veut absolument pas élire !
On dit que nos scrutins sont dépendants aux
alternatives non-pertinentes, parce que la
présence d’un candidat alternatif, ici
Sanders, va affecter l’issue du scrutin.
Et cette dépendance aux alternatives non-pertinentes
est un fléau très problèmatique.
À cause de cela, un scrutin à un tour, encore
plus qu’un système à deux tours, conduit
inéluctablement à un bipartisme, et demande
donc inéluctablement aux citoyens de choisir
un camp parmi 2 !
En fait, c’est même pire que cela.
Pour éviter l’élection de Trump, Sanders
avait tout intérêt à entièrement soutenir
Clinton, même sur les points de désaccord
entre eux.
C’est pour ça que les idées se polarisent
dans nos systèmes démocratiques !
Parce qu’on est inéluctablement dans une
élection à 2 camps, tout citoyen a intérêt
à annoncer son adhésion complète à l’un
des 2 camps, même s’il n’est que très
légèrement plus en accord avec un camp plutôt
que l’autre ! C’est là tout le problème
du dilemme du “vote utile”.
Dans nos systèmes démocratiques, il n’y
a de place que pour deux courants de pensée.
Il y a deux camps, vous avez tout intérêt
à choisir l’un des deux camps.
Pire encore, une fois votre camp choisi, vous
avez tout intérêt à vanter tous les aspects
de votre camp.
Et c’est ça qui, inéluctablement, conduit
à une scission croissante et une bipolarisation
des idéologies politiques.
C’est pour ça que je pense qu’il est
urgent et critique de considérer des systèmes
démocratiques alternatifs ; des systèmes
qui ne favorisent pas, ou en tout cas favorisent
moins, le bipartisme et l'extrême polarisation
politique qui pousse à l'extrémisme ideologique.
Et la clé pour ce faire, c’est de concevoir
des systèmes qui sont indépendants aux alternatives
non-pertinentes et ferment la porte au “vote
utile”.
Et comme on le verra dans les prochains épisodes,
ces Saint-Graal des mathématiques de la démocratie
existent !
Il me paraît donc urgent de les adopter aussi
tôt que possible, pour éviter un futur où
nos sociétés se déchireront de plus en
plus.
C’est l’avenir de l’humanité qui
est
en jeu.
Je supprimerais tout commentaire mentionnant
l’actualité, surtout s’il prend parti.
CGP Grey.
FPTP.
The Good Stuff.
Is America more divided than ever?